Even before first reading? In compliance
with chapter 551 open meetings of the
Texas Government Code, I call to order a
public hearing meeting of the Board of
Trustees of the Austin Independent
School District for Thursday, October
30th, 2025 at 5:30 p.m. A quorum of the
board is physically present at the
Austin ISD Central Office to conduct
this meeting. This meeting is being
broadcast on cable channel 22 through
Spectrum, Astound Broadband, and on
channel 99 through AT&T U-Verse.
Closed captioning in English is
available on these platforms for
individuals who are deaf or hard of
hearing. Welcome and thank you for
joining us.
Next is an opportunity for the public to
share comments with the board. This time
allows speakers to comment publicly
pertaining to the Austin ISD schools uh
school financial integrity rating for
2025. And tonight we have no one who
signed up to speak in person. We have
one person who left a recorded message,
and we will now play that recorded
message for public testimony. So, please
listen carefully.
This is Marie, a parent. Um I appreciate
that the board is reviewing the
financial integrity rating, and I
appreciate what it stands for, but I
think that the district should be clear
about what it does and doesn't do. The
financial integrity rating does not
assess the district expenditures such as
being over budget on the bond, legal fee
expenses, or the size and salaries of HQ
against what is reasonable. Please
address HQ spending, legal fees and
lawsuits, and staffing at HQ. Thank you.
This concludes public testimony. Trust
uh thank you to our caller. And
trustees, are there any questions
seeking clarification?
Uh thank you. As a reminder, please feel
free to share any general comments or
questions with the board by email at
trustees@austinisd.org.
And next up is a pres- presentation on
the Austin ISD school financial
integrity rating for 2025. You might
know that as the first rating, and Mr.
Mr. Segura, would you please introduce
this? Uh absolutely, President Boswell.
I'd like to welcome up Katrina
Montgomery, our Chief Financial Officer,
uh to take us through the first rating
uh overview presentation.
Hello.
Excuse me. Hello, President Boswell. Um
um and other trustees
um and our superintendent. So, today
we're going to go over our first rating,
which is our financial integrity s-
rating system of Texas. This is how TEA
um evaluates the district. So, here's a
quick overview. The rating system
ensures that Texas public schools are
held accountable for the quality of
their financial management practices.
The system is designed to encourage
Texas public schools to better manage
their financial resources to provide the
maximum allocation possible for direct
instructional purposes. So, we're going
to talk about that a lot more in our
next few slides. The 2024-25
data from July 2023 through June 2024
school district school year.
So, assess areas of measurement, there
are 21 indicators that are um evaluated,
but I'm just going to highlight a few
here. Our annual financial report, which
is our audit. We're working on that to
um wrap that up in the next couple of
weeks. Um looking at debt payments, our
terms and compliance, timely payments
made to government agencies, and we're
going to talk about that one a little
bit more in depth.
Um the district's financial solvency,
and various other ratios and financial
measurements.
So, on this slide here, you see that a
superior achievement is the highest
first rating, reflecting strong
financial management, accountability,
and compliance with state standards. And
we went back to 2020-21
through 2024-25. You can see we
consistently had a superior achievement.
And then in 2024-25, we went up to a 95.
So, that was the highest rating we've
had in the last 5 years.
And so, now we're going to go over the
in- the indicators. And the ones that I
will talk to you about are the ones that
changed from last for from 2023-24
through 2024-25.
So, 1 2 and 3 stayed consistent. And
then I'm going to read four because this
is the one that changed. Did the school
district make timely payments to the
Texas Retirement System? We did. Texas
Workforce Commission? We did. Internal
Revenue Service? We did. And
governmental agencies. And you could see
in 2023-24, the rating was passed. In
2024-25, you can see the rating is
failed. We missed in November of 2023 by
one day making our sales tax payment.
And so, since then, that has not
happened, but that is one of the things
that is rated here on the first rating.
Um items six and seven stay consist- um
stay consistent. Eight was the measure
of current assets to current liabilities
ratios for the school district
sufficient to cover short-term debt. And
last year, we had six, and we went up
this year to an eight.
11 and 12 was consistent. 13 was the
school district's administrative cost
ratio equal to or less than the
threshold ratio. Last year, we had an
eight. This year, we improved to a 10.
Approved to a 10.
17 through 21 all stay consistent.
So, indicator 13 is where we look at our
administrative cost ratio, and we want
to ensure with this that we're ensuring
funds are directed primarily to
classrooms.
And so, to the far left, you see 2019
through 2020, where we were we were at
0.0823.
And the TEA standard is at the top,
0.0855.
2020-2021,
we were above that, but just a little
bit. 21-22, we went higher. 22-23, we
went way over the line. But in 2023-24,
you can see that we're below the line.
So, some of the reductions that we've
been making in administrative staff
definitely shows that we're moving
toward spending more money or more of
our funds are going directly to
classrooms.
And then also on indicator 13, we look
at a peer review. So, where are we
against our peers? You still have the
same TEA standard, which is 0.0855.
You have Austin ISD at 0.0835.
And then you have some of our peers that
are small that are doing have lower um
percentages than we do. You have
Arlington, Cypress, but then you also
have Dallas ISD, which is way above the
TEA standard.
As well as Houston is right at the line.
So, other financial indicators, bond
ratings, and financial awards. So, this
slide just talks to us about where we
are. So, all of our rating agencies, we
have the top ratings for those ag- age-
agencies, whether it's Moody's, Fitch,
Kroll, or S&P.
And the um ASBO, Association of School
Business Officials, and the GFOA, the
Government Finance Officers Association,
have both given us the Certificate of
Excellence in Financial Reporting as
well as the material material
budget award.
So, um that is the presentation for
today. Do you have any questions?
Thank you very much for that, Trustee
Hunter.
Yes, ma'am.
Maybe I meant 10.
Hold on. I can't see the number. One
second.
>> It's the bar graph.
There. There. Okay. So, we have the 23
So, the 23-24
is our 25 rating. Yes.
>> So, then we will see When will we see
what has gone on for 2024-25 this past
academic year?
>> 2024-25, we will see this time next
year. This time next year. Okay. So, I
didn't understand that it was a whole uh
very large
very large district. Um hopefully the
number will look even better for us cuz
I know you've been doing a lot of work.
So, thank you for that. And then the
next slide, which is 11.
Um
just out of curiosity because that is a
huge dip. Can I'm not sure if you have
this information on hand or if the
superintendent has it. What is the
student population of Cy-Fair?
I don't It's over 100,000. I I I from
what I It's It's high. I'm not sure.
It's big. I can find it. And their slide
also, they're both very good.
Okay. And so, I just was wondering if
there's any um learning to be had or any
wisdom to gather. Um
maybe a partner share. I don't know how
that happens.
118,000.
118,000. 118,000.
Um
and I believe they also uh
Is this the school district with with no
Fs, no Ds?
I I can't remember exactly. So, I don't
want to put you on the spot with that,
but I'm just wondering how they're
managing to to cuz I don't really know
anything about their demographics. I
just haven't looked. I can Google it,
I'm sure. But if there's just anything
that we can learn from someone who seems
to be doing
So, their demogra- demographics are not
ours.
>> Okay. This is what I'm
talk Yeah, I got you. Okay. This is just
what I was wondering. Yeah, I I can
certainly happy to supplement this
document with either total student
population or demographic percentages
and breakdowns. These are very different
school districts.
You know,
they're very different.
Cypress is not a urban school district
is the first thing I would say. Dallas,
Houston, and Austin are.
You know, at least classified as urban,
but we can share that information. No, I
I don't want you to do any more extra
work. I was just wondering for for my
own learning and I think it's part of
the conversation that I'm having with
people.
When you have a bigger lift, it's
harder. It takes more and I think that
that's that's something maybe we haven't
communicated well
to our community that it's it's not the
same. So, you can look at these numbers
on a chart, but understand that the work
that's going on is not these blue boxes.
It's much bigger and it did cost money.
It just does. Thank you.
Thank you. Anyone else?
So, I just want to express gratitude for
that administrative administrative cost
ratio. I know we saw it spike
when we were working to look a little
more like Dallas in the way we ran
things and I think we see that disparity
in the chart with when we look at our
peer or other Texas districts and I know
since then we have been working really
hard to pull it down and I think it's
important to note that the number we're
seeing is two budget cycles ago. So, we
have two additional years currently that
we have continued to kind of move in
a more classroom focused direction and I
think as our resources get tighter,
I really appreciate that work. I know a
lot has gone into it and I know that's a
very specific ask and that I and some of
the other trustees have had and I do
appreciate trustee Hunter's question
about Northside and Cy-Fair. Northside
does look more like us than Cy-Fair
does.
Bigger, but but has some diversity.
That's where I'm from originally and
yes, I'm a Northside ISD graduate.
And I did pull their org charts and
they're much flatter at the top. They
have fewer layers at the top. So, I
would really love to learn from them as
we start building our budget
for the next year. We know that we're
going to have to make some more cuts and
I would continue to kind of look at and
learn from what they've done and see if
there's anything worth borrowing.
I know there are lots of ways to model,
but that's just a a question I have as
we look at our next budget. Thank you.
So, one thing I would
I would
I would offer that we need to understand
more about I know these school
districts.
Each one has a different story, a
different place that they're kind of in
and they're I'm not going to talk about
any one of them specifically, but I
would say that um
there's an understanding I think needs
to be shared before we begin to make
direct comparisons.
Um
Just I'll I'll say that.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. And if it were if you
points different, but if they're doing
it with that much of a difference, maybe
we can continue moving in that
direction. It's really not to copy, but
to understand that there are lots of
ways to do it. So, I also
I also coding matters. Um you know, I
just be really really clear when you're
of a certain size and you code centrally
even though you you distribute across
our our campuses. Like an example of
this might be instructional coaches. So,
we code those centrally because we want
the autonomy to distribute them as
needed where if I code to the campus,
then that's going to show up on the
other side. So, I just there's just
there's just a lot that kind of goes
into
the way this breaks down. So, I just
want to learn more before I
offer a direct comparison. Yeah.
Absolutely.
Thank you. Any other questions?
All right.
Thank you and thank you, Ms. Montgomery,
for the work and the presentation and
I'm really
glad to see that remaining so strong and
so high. I know in a time when we're
really stretching every dollar as far as
it can go, it's really nice to see that
measure
that we are considered financially sound
even as we're really working to
remain that way in a really challenging
time. And I know you're doing a lot of
work to make that happen. I know you're
doing a lot of work to make that happen
and thank you both.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay, at this time we will adjourn our
public hearing, take a short break, and
then return to open our regular voting
meeting. Secretary Gonzalez, drive a
motion to adjourn the meeting. So moved.
Thank you. This meeting is adjourned at
5:44 p.m.